hello and welcome to this video playing
xj5 t declines my bank oh that's not
good well I don't mind really but could
get them don't get this this active play
in such a position so yeah this is an
interesting line
do you play d4 insists here or not okay
let's go d4 it's got Knight a 4 of
course hmm actually surprising that he
takes so quickly yeah young yeah I'm
okay really okay
just prepare d3 okay so he's one of
those guys who just plays plays plays
and then wonders why it's got a bad
position but we'll see so what is that
where do you go with this thing we
Knight c3 was a thread anyway
and now comes the big thing here
I think that's check for a second if I
have something better word this is kind
of clear that it should be done okay so
you can grab the horn
do I have something better than the
training now Queen age five comes into
consideration just attacking I mean his
position is absolutely not coordinated
at all maybe he's got some Bishop three
now then Bishop defiles good okay so
this is probably strong I have 95 also
coming blank on ending here it's not
enough
we really want to checkmate if someone
place this kind of stuff
the app ship t5 is one way I wonder if
there's something better you I have it's
good yeah so let's do it okay
95 even as an option okay so here take a
night if high of whom or just go back in
1095
nine f4 probably
yeah I don't like that I'm drifting into
slide time problem him
okay let's play the ending maybe this is
an at the end easier to play it's upon
and also the far better coordination I
don't see three is really an annoying
piece for wide
[Music]
in the other 95 right so let's it should
be fairly easy win situ was actually
more precisely they didn't even have to
check but it doesn't doesn't matter all
that much
check quite recently
okay Alec I mean I really should check
mate somewhere but I didn't see it I
didn't see it yeah I just played the
opening far too quickly I mean 93 six
already is bad really I mean it just
develops me the thing is I have to worry
about 95 for example in case of Bishop
e6 let's just say castles here and I
want to do this then he has this idea
okay this should be five given by the
engine but I mean there is no need to
take really but give me all the Tempe
this is weakening c3 one second
another quick move and now it's already
busted and there's no way out there 93
okay yeah I'm not really happy with my
conversion that looked okay but somehow
I didn't didn't find something decisive
her I mean the ending is of course very
good but so I was thinking I should be
some some sort of some sort of mate but
yeah that makes it extremely easy but
it's it's too much really the pollen c3
and I've got the more active pieces okay
let is it easy ending because he gets
into six one pretty quickly
okay guys thanks for watching